police had released this photo of 22
year old robert crimo the third and the
make and model of his car late sunday
afternoon a few hours later a police
officer in north chicago spotted the car
and following a brief pursuit crimea was
taken into custody the person of
interest is now being taken to the
highland park police department where
we're going to begin the
you know the next phase of the
investigation and speak with this person
to make sure or see if in fact he is
connected to this incident
the shooting took place about nine
kilometers south from where crimo was
apprehended at an event in the wealthy
chicago suburb of highland park
witnesses say they first assumed they
were hearing fireworks at the annual 4th
of july parade
but it soon became clear that this was
yet another mass shooting in the usa we
ran behind the building and i put my my
son in a dumpster
and
he sit there with his dog
and i went back to look for the rest of
my family i left him with someone there
so that i can go back to get my phone
and find the rest of my family because
they ran
away also and
it was just horrible
police say the gunman fired at
spectators from a rooftop overlooking
the festivities with a high-powered
rifle of the several children taken to
hospital at least one was in critical
condition at the time medical
authorities say the age range of the
wounded is eight to eighty five they
were gunshot wounds and it varied from
abdomen to limbs
and such but
the crews were on scene very quickly
there was bystanders as well that were
under date as well
they were
quick to tie tourniquets and do bleeding
control
just 10 days ago joe biden signed
legislation seen as the first major gun
safety law in 30 years however it did
not institute any restrictions on the
purchase of assault weapons as gun
control advocates have recommended at
independence day celebrations of the
white house the president acknowledged
that more had to be done we all heard
what happened today
but each day we're reminded
there's nothing guaranteed about our
democracy
nothing guaranteed about our way of life
we have to fight for it
defend it and earn it
by voting
there are approximately 10 mass
shootings a week in the united states
defined as an incident with four or more
shots not including the shooter it's a
uniquely american phenomenon and in fact
on this fourth of july there were at
least six other mass shootings around
the country according to the gun
violence archive shihabra tennessee al
jazeera